Donald Trump has imposed a new tax on
solar panels that are imported from
other countries solar panels a
technology that's great for the
environment it's great for American jobs
even if the panel's themselves are from
other countries and Donald Trump is
imposing a 30% tax I've told you this
before Trump for a while has had the
exact wrong positions on energy right he
wants to resuscitate a dying industry of
coal mining which employs now I think we
said fewer people than the fast food
chain Arby's fewer people I think then
than JCPenney is well then you tell me
that Pat and per industry per market
conditions the coal industry is an
industry that should be allowed to die
instead Donald Trump has put taxes on
solar panels which is an industry that
has the potential to create way more
jobs in the future and I know that this
is also really arousing for lack of a
better term to the fossil fuel industry
at large because anything that slows
down the solar industry is good for
fossil fuels now because Trump is only
putting the tax on imported solar panels
he's saying this is going to be very
good for domestically produced solar
panels but like with most of these
issues it's way more complicated and
nuanced then Donald Trump is making it
out to be it's true that there are a few
American solar panel manufacturers that
have filed complaints over cheap
imported solar panels from different
parts of Asia the problem is that the
solar panel manufacturing is a small
part of what we would call the American
solar industry there's the installers
there's the drivers customer service
salespeople it's a long list of jobs
that are supported by the solar industry
regardless of where the panels actually
come from but that's only one part the
other problem is that the two companies
that filed complaints to begin with that
led to this manufacture their solar
panels in the United States but their
foreign companies the two companies are
soon Eva and Solar world and they're
Chinese and German respects
actively so which it is much more muddy
of an issue than hey these two American
solar panel companies are getting
crushed let's help them with the tax and
the big winner is coal this tariff is
expected to block about seven and a half
gigawatts of solar capacity from being
installed over the next four years that
energy has to come from somewhere else
and it's going to be pushed over to the
fossil fuel industry including coal and
for claiming to be the party of the free
market and letting supply and demand
aside taxing solar panels is sort of the
opposite of allowing the invisible hand
of supply and demand to run its course
the tax is also going to cost twenty
three thousand jobs in places like Texas
and Florida and South Carolina red
states that voted for Donald Trump again
because there's so many ancillary
industries that rely on having solar
panels to install it's terrible and it's
the exact opposite of what supposedly
Donald Trump's overarching philosophy is
which is one of being sort of a free
market supply and demand guy even though
we know that with the right it's only
the free market it's only the invisible
hand it's only supply and demand when it
benefits the industries they want to
prop up and other otherwise they're all
about government intervention so a
horrible move by Donald Trump on an
issue he claims to know a lot about but
really just doesn't today's program is
made possible in part by wink let me
give you a task pick out a wine that you
are going to love for sure but the catch
is it can't be a wine that you've had
before where would you start
that's where wink comes in spell WI and
C wink makes it easy for you to discover
great wines because every month they
ship you wines that have already been
matched to your taste and personalized
to you there are wines that you are
going to love that you'd never know
about if you didn't go to try wink comm
slash Pakman and fill out the palate
profile quiz they ask you a few simple
questions like how do you like your
coffee
do you like raspberries or blueberries
and then you get great wine
that have been personalized to you
delivered right to your door and the
great thing is that as you drink more
wines you rate them yes or no and the
wink system will continue to improve its
recommendations to you personalized
recommendations for delicious wines that
you can try each month never a
membership fee you can skip any month
you can cancel anytime and wink has a
100% satisfaction guarantee so you will
never pay for a bottle that you don't
like and for a limited time you can get
$20 off when you go to try wink comm /
Pakman that's t ry winc comm /p a que ma
n for $20 off last time that is tri wink
comm / Pakman